hola valentino la verdad que este día
sábado está haciendo muy especial aquí
en berlín pero es porque se está
realizando mañana también la maratón de
la ciudad por lo tanto hay mucho
movimiento yo me encuentro aquí en la
puerta de brandenburgo donde pasa ese
maratón así que la ciudad está muy
ajetreada hay también muchos cortes de
tráfico pero es cierto por ejemplo que
hace un rato estuvimos en un barrio del
oeste de la ciudad de schönebeck ahí en
los partidos todavía están entregando
folletos tratando de convencer a los
indecisos porque como tú bien decías los
partidos llegan muy muy peleados
separados por algunos puntos y nunca en
esta campaña ha habido un partido que
lleve la delantera siempre ha habido uno
que ha sido el que está más votado según
los sondeos obviamente pero por muy
pocos puntos ya sea los verdes los
socialdemócratas o los
democratacristianos de angela merkel por
lo tanto hoy día los partidos se están
agotando todas sus estrategias porque no
se sabe lo que va a pasar mañana
valentina erika usted lo estaba
mencionando ya las campañas habían
cerrado el viernes pero estos son actos
no oficiales para tratar de convencer a
quienes no sean de sí realmente se
consiguen votos a última hora
parece que sí valentina efectivamente no
hay silencio electoral como tú decías
los socialdemócratas están hoy en post
aunque además es el feudo del candidato
donde se presenta también como candidato
a diputado los democratacristianos están
en renania del norte-westfalia que es su
feudo también sólo los ecologistas no
realizan actividad hoy como decíamos es
tan imprevisible lo que va a pasar y
además no hay ningún tema de campaña que
sea fuerte en el año 2017 estaba el tema
migratorio y el ascenso de la extrema
derecha pero este año puede ser la
ecología puede ser la vivienda la
tecnología la necesaria modernización
del país por lo tanto yo creo los
partidos se están agotando todas sus
fuerzas para intentar acoger a esas
personas que aún no se deciden y que se
calculan como en un 20 un 25 por ciento
valentina erika sabemos que ningún
partido tiene la fuerza para lograr una
mayoría absoluta en el parlamento porque
las alianzas serán clave brevemente
cuánto tiempo podría tardar la
conformación de un gobierno
efectivamente lo que se sabe es que va a
ser un gobierno tripartito seguro pero
no podemos decir nada la última vez
fueron cinco meses antes en el año 2013
un mes todo puede pasar pero la
canciller merkel mañana seguirá siendo
la canciller de este país eso es seguro
y al menos por algunas semanas valentina
erika muchas gracias por esta ampliación
estamos muy pendientes de lo que ocurre
esta tarde y mañana en alemania